señor chaudhuri que cree que busca
bukele con este nuevo proyecto
buenas tardes pues para mí es
internacional este es como otra medida
que no va a aprender realmente como las
causas raíces de la violencia en el país
como la sociedad civil y en el salvador
la comunidad internacional ha dicho
reiteradamente que el gobierno de salud
tiene que diseñar políticas públicas que
realmente como atienden las causas
raíces con un enfoque de derechos
humanos pero otra vez como este nuevo
desarrollo como demuestra que el
gobierno va a seguir con una política de
encarcelamiento masivo
que no va a realmente como resolver los
problemas de violencia en el país si
tanto su organización como otras ong han
denunciado violaciones a los derechos
humanos se denuncia entre otras cosas
detenciones arbitrarias temen que este
nuevo proyecto suponga mayor opacidad de
las detenciones y en el trato a los
detenidos
si la amnistía internacional ha
documentado detenciones arbitrarias
masivas como en el contexto del del
régimen de excepción hemos documentado
situaciones en que las personas han sido
detenidas únicamente por tener tatuajes
por vivir en comunidades como pobres y
marginadas y también como pues por tener
como convicciones
criminales previas aunque como ya ya ya
ya no como servido como estas
convicciones entonces estamos como
realmente muy preocupados sobre ésta
esta nueva cárcel y la posibilidad de
detenciones arbitrarias como siguiendo
masivamente como en el país además de
pues hemos documentado también como la
situación de las condiciones carcelarias
y según los pronunciamientos del
presidente sobre esta nueva cárcel como
también la idea es seguir con con esta
misma dinámica y entonces realmente como
sí sí es muy preocupante también como
la posibilidad de violaciones masivas a
raíz de la concepción de esta nueva casa
si usted habla precisamente de las
condiciones carcelarias encerrar a todos
los pandilleros y supuestos pandilleros
juntos podría suponer un riesgo de
aumento de la violencia entre ellos
ayudaría a esto a acabar con la
violencia en el país
bueno en realidad como no el problema
que hemos documentado es que
como actualmente como hay violencia
dentro de las de las cárceles en el
salvador por parte de precisamente si
son pandillas
ejercido como en contra de otros
personas que han sido como detenidas
como arbitrariamente entonces en
realidad como lo que hemos visto es
descubrimos violaciones masivas de los
derechos humanos si se han denunciado
que bajo el régimen de excepción se
vulneran también derechos de varios
sectores de la población como el
colectivo lgv te manejan información al
respecto
en el marco del régimen de excepción
como no tenemos como información
específica sobre sobre personas
detenidas pero pero como es un problema
histórico en el sabor como violencia y
didácticamente en contra de
discriminación en contra de esa
población
pues ese régimen excepcional ha afectado
a todos los sectores y seguramente como
a los sectores más vulnerables
incluyendo como mujeres y personas como
de diversas orientaciones sexuales